[Music]
this is the ramsay
show you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
this hour is going to be devoted to
[Music]
america's largest legalized fraud
[Music]
timeshares the timeshare industry has
milked
primarily middle and lower income
americans completely dry
to the tune of billions and billions of
dollars with unbelievably fraudulent
sales tactics
offering and promising things that they
never deliver
including an asset that is not an asset
an asset by the way by definition in
financial terms is something that you
can sell and people will give you money
for it
your couch is more of an asset
than a time share is because somebody
might actually buy your used couch no
one will buy your timeshare
it has absolutely no value
it has as much value as your reservation
at the day's end
you want to try to sell your reservation
at the days inn
nope nobody wants to buy your
reservation at the day's end
and the only difference is the day's
ends are actually there and people
actually do get to sleep there
occasionally that would be the
difference if you have had a time share
horror story we're going to devote this
hour to giving you
a voice
you get to speak you get to tell your
story call right now the phone number is
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five five
two two
five i wanna hear your time share
horror stories and they will be a
warning
to unsuspecting people that otherwise
might go in
the tiger cage
if you haven't heard the tiger cage is
this you're walking down the street
innocently one day and a guy runs up to
you and says hey
we're going to give you free passes for
the entire year
to the zoo
in order to get those passes though you
need to spend two hours in the tiger
cage petting the tiger
warning the tiger has not been fed in
several days and he's a wee bit
greedy
and hungry
and so you go into the tiger cage and
you pet the tiger for two hours which of
course means you get eaten
this is what going to a time share
presentation in order to get free
tickets to anything
is
you're going in there they're going to
keep you in there 4 to 12 hours
they're going to badger the ever loving
crud out of you
they're gonna use every technique and
form a pressure on the planet
and suddenly your idea of i got a free
room while i'm on vacation i got free
tickets to the water park while i'm on
vacation has turned into the meeting
from hell
and in order to just be set free from
the tiger cage
you will sign anything
one of the worst among the timeshare
companies is the largest
diamond international
courthouse news ventura california an 81
year old man claims in court that
diamond resorts international a
timeshare club defrauded him of fifty
thousand dollars and keeps trying to get
more
lewis wolf claims diamond resorts
international club and six affiliates
used high pressure sales tactics to open
credit cards in his name
run up bills on them before the
plaintiff even realized the cards
existed
and charged him more than fifty thousand
dollars for quote membership services
in diamond resorts international
entities
wolfe sued diamond resorts on march 8th
in superior court
he claims the abusive sales pitches on
the phone and in person could last four
or five hours and despite the fifty
thousand dollars they already took from
him
he says it can they continue to harass
him for upgrades to his quote membership
he's just a senior with the sort of
normal cognitive challenges that comes
from being an 81 year old senior senior
wolf's attorney eric ridley told
courthouse news ridley said his client
is typical of many people his age and
susceptible to high pressure sales which
can be overwhelming get this one
diamond international sends buses
to senior communities
to take them to nevada
and once they get a name there will be a
non-stop barrage of phone calls
one diamond timeshare owner told morgan
diamond is much more ambitious and
aggressive and downright nasty in their
sales presentations
diamond just has an amazing reputation
of being rough on people they reported
845 million dollars in revenue last year
according to the times article
which cities
which cites two other lawsuits similar
to wolves one in florida one in
california
so
maybe you're like the
81 year old louis wolf
or you know someone who is or maybe you
just went in the tiger cage and you've
had an experience some of the stories
are downright funny
the bizarre behavior of some of these
timeshare salespeople they are some
unusually scummy people working in an
unusually scummy business
you don't like me calling you scum well
i'll help you
you won't be scum when you go get a job
where you're not ripping people off
you're right there with payday lenders
your scum
you're screwing people and you know it
you should be ashamed of yourself your
grandmother should box your little ears
for behaving the way you're behaving
selling this crap to people it's
ridiculous and it's out of control
and it's a horrible product i hope i
haven't been unclear if you've got a
story you call me triple eight eight two
five five two two five mario is with us
in akron ohio hey mari tell me your
story
hey dave thanks for having me on today
sure um first of all my husband michael
and i have used time shares for over 30
years
so i probably have a little bit more
information on time shares than the
average person okay
uh one thing that you should know about
is in addition to the maintenance fees
which most
all-time shares you are responsible for
if you want to exchange your week you
are going to deal with either rci which
is affiliated with windom or interval
international
now there is a separate fee
to belong to these clubs as well and
that's like 100 maybe 149
a year
depending on how many years you commit
to
then when you go to exchange your week
even though you have paid
your maintenance fees with your
own company
you're going to pay these exchange
companies
249 a week if you're traveling in the
u.s
299
a week if you're traveling international
oh my god why didn't you just stay at
the ritz
well it would have been cheaper what
exactly i'm just explaining you some of
the other fees that people don't even
know i know yeah i mean this is amazing
hey i want to hear the rest of your
story hold on with me through this break
i'll be right back with you
with what you i mean you paid 25 000 to
stay at a hotel
i mean that's what you just did
this is i mean come on people
how in the world do they get away with
this
ah because we've been letting them
not anymore they're my new hobby
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 a month by
switching to pure top just go to
feartalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
it's a time share
hour as we talk about america's
largest legalized fraud
one company diamond international doing
almost a billion dollars a year you know
what a billion is that's a thousand
million
that's a lot of people getting ripped
off all right mari is with us she was
telling us that she's been
been buying and
dealing with uh women i did something
wrong they're dealing with time shares
for uh 30 years and she's talking about
the fees for the exchanges the annual
fees and then the exchange fee per
company and per transaction to change
that's if you can get a week lined up
and you were i had to cut you off in the
middle of a commercial there so tell me
the rest of the story mari
okay well now i'm going to tell you
about somebody who has done this for 30
years who should have been
a little bit smarter
in
february of 2018
we went to vallarta gardens
for a presentation
this is in mexico just north of puerto
vallarta
and you know we were in the tigers cage
and we did not purchase you know
held firm no no
don't want it don't want it well you
already own some time shares at that
point right
right and we've bought nars off the
secondary market okay yes we had owned
but you know nope we didn't want this so
these time shares are famous for you're
not getting out you've got the
exit it's almost like the exit interview
but then
you know they bring you in something
else
should have known better dave but i paid
8 100
for
travel
package it was supposed to be like on
the lines of travelocity where you're
getting like bulk airfare
you know you can do things with like
viking cruise lines you know alarms
should have been going off
but the one thing that made me feel a
little bit safe
the company
we bought it at vallarta gardens in
mexico but the company was a united
states company getaway
travel services in nebraska
and i even talked to them when i was in
mexico
saw the website everything looked good
well
here it is
2021 i have not been able
to book any
trips with them use airfare nothing
i do
still hassle them to this day
trying to get the 8 100 back i
went to the attorney general for
nebraska they couldn't do anything but
this week i did
let them know that 20 million listeners
would be finding out about their company
good
good very well done okay
and so the name of this ripoff
organization again is what
getaway
travel
services in nebraska and and what they
really mean is now that we got your 8100
would you just get away
[Laughter]
i am sort of a person that you know what
i i'm just gonna harass them yeah i
would
i would have eighty one hundred dollars
worth of fun out of it anyway messing
with
just messing with them to go in i wonder
if you could buy i want to make an ad
you could buy like in the local paper or
something
in nebraska no in puerto vallarta
well
down there it's a little bit different
that's why i was glad that they were in
the united states but that really didn't
turn out to be good and i don't know but
if a tourist happened to be looking
through a tourist magazine and one was
going to wander into the getaway travel
tiger cage and they saw your ad that
said
i got screwed by getaway stay away from
them get away get away
um
you know that might be fun i don't know
you can have all kinds of fun with this
you might as well because you've been
taken there's no question about that i'm
so sorry
hey thanks for sharing the story is a
warning
warning warning
douglas is with us in los angeles
douglas tell us about your timeshare
mess
okay well um
we've been timeshare owners for uh five
years i'm sorry and we bought we we know
that time share was not um
not a good money investment
and
we went ahead and did it because it was
the first time
our whole family or my our family our
kids and myself saw my husband relaxed
and our kids are in high school
so this is the first time he relaxed
so
um we went ahead and did it it turns out
that the trip is what he relaxed not a
time share
well we've gone on trips before
but this place is just really relaxing
i'm sure there's other places but anyway
um
we
went and um july
19th i mean july 2019 we upgraded from a
presidential to a penthouse suite
wow that must be nice
and this how was this week um was it
nice
yes it's very nice how many times have
you stayed in
um
just one because we've only upgraded one
oh i see okay
okay so
anyway this last trip at the beginning
of this month
we um
they put us in
a presidential suite thinking that we
had a presidential but really we have a
penthouse
so we
we wanted to upgrade you know we wanted
something bigger for our next vacation
so we met with a salesperson on our own
will
unfortunately
and um
we asked her for
a copy of our contract we asked her
twice
and so we could verify what we owned and
she left the table twice both times
returning to the table without anything
in her hand
and
instead she confirmed that we had a
presidential contract and that's the one
that we signed in 2018
which is now void
or which is void so
um
she basically
um
brought in the inducement i mean she
tricked us into
thinking we had a presidential when we
all the time had a penthouse you'd
already paid for the upgrade once and
then you paid for it again
exactly
oh my gosh i just want your listeners to
be yeah which company is this
this is it's called it's in cabo san
lucas it's a small company called grand
solmar they have four properties
um
three of them are right next door to
each other and then there's a brand new
one out a ways
and um
i just want everyone to be to realize
what we did do is um i had a lawyer help
me with the letter we wrote a letter
um to the manager the sales manager
who's still there and he's american
and he's the one who sold us in 2019 so
we know
fedex a letter that you have to have a
signature for they don't have certified
mail down in mexico
and
um
within 30 days if they don't respond
favorably
we will um
the letter says we will contact the bb
the better business bureau of las vegas
which that's where their
financial
handling company
is
and
we will open the case with the mexican
federal
consumer protection department which is
called pro-feco
so i don't know how this is going to end
but um because we just fedex the letter
yesterday but i want your listeners to
be aware that
you know we asked for that you can tell
a timeshare salesman is lying if his
mouth is moving
yes and we're like
you know they they she's she was an
expert she we she got our trust from the
get-go
we shared family stories pictures of her
kids
i mean
it was just and you know so from now on
i mean we we learned
we learned cheaper in a hotel you know
even if we if even if we can just recoup
our
even if we give up our deposit
and we don't have to pay the rest of the
contract
i mean we'll be happy yeah i know that
sounds awful but no it doesn't sound
awful it sounds like you got screwed and
they should let you go
i mean that's what fraud does even in
mexico go figure
wow
amazing
what a scummy scummy business
wow
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
we're talking time shares this hour and
what a horrible thing they are and what
former people worked in that business
it's absolutely out of control diamond
international west gate marriott windham
diamond being purchased now for billions
by hilton
so hilton's going to go ahead and mess
up their name by buying the largest
timeshare
company out there that screws more
people than anyone else
see what happens is people buy these
things for 15 or 20 thousand dollars and
they're almost never able to actually
use them
let's protect not even on the week that
they bought
that this comes up time and time and
time again
the aarp put out the 10 costliest scams
to the elderly
number one romance scams 83 million
number seven time share sales 17 million
number 10 timeshare resales
12 million
30 million dollars a year that the aarp
estimates is being stolen from
the elderly scams is what they called it
scams go figure that
man something else stacia is with us in
tampa florida hi stasia is estacia stasi
how do you say it it's it's stacia
stacia i didn't even get close sorry
about that how can i help
well thanks for having me on your show
and um thanks for having this um i think
it's an important segment
to help get the facts out to people
before they spend money on these
programs so
um back in 2001 i received an offer in
the mail this is one that i couldn't
refuse right yeah right i think it was
for 450 dollars for five days and four
nights including a rental car and it was
at a marriott property on maui how could
i pass that up maui
so i knew that a timeshare presentation
was included so my eyes were sort of
open and i had friends that had time
shares and they seemed to enjoy it but
we never really talked about the money
part anyway
and i'm strong i'm not going to buy a
stinking time share i'm just going to
enjoy and treat my mom to an inexpensive
right right so we know i bought or i
wouldn't be on a segment right yeah
so you went the tiger cage and you got
eaten
oh yeah so as i was preparing for early
retirement i put it on my list of things
to do to get rid of the annual expense
um
you know i could spend the money going
elsewhere and getting to hawaii from
florida
to
was way too much travel
so i kicked the can down the road
because i listened to your program now
i'm not saying that you advise
procrastination
i just heard all the horror stories and
so i procrastinated because i didn't i
didn't want to deal with it which is
very rare for me
so over the years i did simple math to
see without if i was getting the value
but i corrected my simple math when i
started sending information to your show
and i learned that my simple math was
really me lying to myself
and i didn't want you to catch me and
ignoring the truth
so my original payment was for ten
thousand nine hundred dollars for every
other year to to um stay in maui
and then i upgraded to their point
system i think that was around 2011.
um i guess i imagine the salesperson's
children were going without shoes and
food or something i don't know what i
what i was thinking
but that upgrade was two thousand
dollars so by this time i'm in it for a
sump cost of 12 900.
i paid maintenance every year for an
every other year program and that
started at 450 dollars in 2001
and it ended at 1300 in 2020.
and in that time frame
this property is falling apart all that
maintenance
well in every other year at occupancy so
i only use it nine times
so i reached out to marriott in january
2020 and they paid me three thousand
dollars to take back my twelve thousand
dollars twelve thousand niner dollars is
current cost um i thought it was a
bargain given the horror stories i've
heard it was pretty simple process
marriott actually gave you three
thousand dollars
yes sir
wow
you really came out
but i didn't no i know you didn't but i
mean compared i mean because marriott i
mean
there's some good people that work at
the hotels and stuff but the leadership
team at marriott man you could tell
they're lying if their mouth's moving
too oh my god we've had all kinds of
trouble with those people it's a
horrible company at the top so i'm
really shocked wow look at you and i got
out i got out before the for the
pandemic so i don't know what that would
look like today i don't know what those
fees would raise up to today but you did
good i mean really i mean i know you i
know you feel like you got messed up you
could get messed over but but i mean
that's impressive if i if everybody
could get three thousand dollars back
from marriott that had been screwed by
marriott on a timeshare
well they'd be shut down
maybe it was because it was so old you
know i purchased back in 2001 somewhere
i don't know you just caught the right
person on a bad day wow i love it
that's good that's good news well hey
i'll just tell you if you're out there
and you have a marriott time share and
you went out of it i'd call them and try
to do what she did that's pretty
incredible it'd be great if marriott got
hit by three thousand dollars for
everybody they've screwed on a timeshare
that'd be amazing i don't think they'd
be open anymore
but um that'd be amazing very cool hey
man thanks for thanks for sharing your
story if you have a time share story
good or bad maybe you love your time
share the three percent of people do
three percent of people that have a time
share just love it
i mean what kind of comp what kind of an
industry stays open with a 97
dissatisfaction ratio
i mean who can stay no restaurant in the
world i mean if you started going okay
97 of mcdonald's customers think they
suck
three percent thinks it's nutritious and
awesome
you know
but they can't stay open on that right
can you imagine i mean 97
of coca-cola drinkers hate it
how do you stay open
oh my gosh if 97 of dave ramsey
listeners
thought i was horrible
they would quit listening
hypothetically oh my gosh
that's i mean that'd be like
this is amazing
marriott here's another mayor out here's
a note i just got on marriott by the way
if you have a time sharing story call
right now triple eight eight two five
five two marriott vacation club
salespeople are super trained used car
sales people
this is a posting online they tell you
how easy it is to book trust me it is
all
fabrication
i could not book a week in october
eleven months in advance
costs
how about twenty thousand dollars for
your week of time share seven hundred
fifty dollars for annual maintenance
fees 104 dollars to trade your week for
points 99 for interval membership 84 to
book your week and oh yeah 79 to cancel
after canceling even due to death and
immediate family you have 60 days to use
your week at a resort
good luck with that
check the figures
booking fancy hotels is much cheaper and
you don't have to stay a full week at
the same location
and you get the week you want
without booking it a full year in
advance
trust me
stay away from marriott vacation clubs
trust me
signed a true sucker
this is an online post right here
and this stuff just goes on and on and
on and on and on
oh here's another diamond resort one
these guys
in 2019 we were visiting a diamond
resorts location and were offered a
discount four-day trip to palm springs
if we attended a time share presentation
while there
the staff pressured us relentlessly into
making a purchase while at the
presentation we were told that these
resorts were for the exclusive use of
members that this was a real estate
investment it's not
and that not traveling more with our
family made us bad parents
see that's when you should have punched
the guy and left
finally we felt that we needed to make a
purchase not only to leave but so that
our children could experience the
lifestyle that the representative was
promising
oh my god
after that day we continued to get
hounded with calls from diamond
employees asking us when we would be
attending a welcome presentation every
time we tried to book it nothing was
available
not only can we not book rooms that
would accommodate our family we receive
bills for maintenance fees that continue
to rise
what are we continuing to pay for this
has become such a burden on us and
diamond is unwilling to help
well of course they're unwilling to help
the tiger
eats until the tiger is full and then he
yawns and takes a nap
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
america's largest legalized fraud
timeshares we spend an hour on it
occasionally just to make sure you know
that you are getting screwed if you love
your timeshare or you hate your
timeshare or you have a great story we'd
love to talk to you the phone number is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five larry loves his time share hey
larry how are you
doing good dave thank you
cool so tell me tell me what you like
about it and where is it
well uh we won one in branson and one in
eureka springs arkansas our first one
was eureka springs um i i did have a
timeshare in colorado that i bought in a
bankruptcy that was used for skiing we
went ahead and let that one go because
the the yearlies did go up
um
but the two i have uh
the yearly fees have not gone up over
gosh darn 25 years so what are the
what's the annual what's the annual
the one is 4 40 a year the other is
seven and a quarter
um for a week we use them for
go ahead so for one week
yeah that's for a week uh but we use
them we use them to trade and if you if
you know johnny morris he owns big cedar
down in branson
their sister resort the wilderness club
is right next door we trade into their
day yeah we enjoy the heck out of it
uh we use the branson resort strictly
for family reunions that we go to yearly
and and we've we've traded all over the
country but we've we've
as i told the screener
you know my father did not vacation and
when i got out of
veterinary school
third floor
our very first time here down in
eureka springs the gentleman was very
low pressure
he gave us the tour he said we're not
high pressure here go have dinner if
this is something you like come back
tomorrow we'll pay we'll sign papers
and and we liked what we saw
and for us the experience was wonderful
now those are those independently owned
or they owned by one of these other
companies that we were talking about
uh well they're you know they're they're
related rci
at the resort exchange company but
that's just an association that's not
they don't they're they're in who owns
them
uh
i the well the homeowners as far as
holiday island down in eureka springs
and in branson
unit owners you know it's i couldn't
tell you who owns it
per se all i know is
it's been good to us because we've known
how to use it you know
so you bought one of them
point of sale you bought it on the
property did you buy the and you bought
one out of bankruptcy that you let go
out in colorado the the other one did
you buy it on the property or did you
buy it on out of bankruptcy we did we
did uh down in branson we bought that
one on property okay um
and um i'll be honest we wish we'd gone
out to the wilderness club first because
the wilderness club is absolutely
beautiful
um right on lake uh right on table rock
lake and
if folks are you know folks are
listening they know what i'm talking
about um but but again i understand the
times
time share scam i've had quite a few
clients
that we've talked about it but uh you
know i've i've sold my weeks to clients
they've gone down there enjoyed the heck
out of them
um i've
used them for auctions in churches and
the parishioners have used them and so
i've i've had a variety of reasons for
using mine
um i definitely understand the scams
what did you what did you pay for them
up front
uh
the eureka springs we paid 4 500 the
bankruptcies were 1700.
now branson at grand crown uh was 12
grand okay um and and so
uh but i had specific reasons uh we
weren't you know we knew what we were
getting into when we bought them and we
go to a nice place every year
for our reunion uh we trade into
we trade into the wilderness club every
january and take a week off before we
start our our practices for the year
it's a
r r for us and and we get the shelter
for the family and
um you don't want to leave that resort
yeah i mean
look up look up big cedar and you'll
understand johnny morris doesn't do
anything wrong i understand got you cool
well i'm glad you're liking it good i
appreciate your reporting in that's fair
that's a fair part of the part of the
story as well we appreciate you thanks
larry appreciate you sharing that open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five if you have a time
share story
uh according to a survey done by the
university of central florida 87 percent
of people hate their time shares
according to a study done by the time
share industry 87 percent of people love
their time shares
i wonder who's telling the truth
and we saw a survey the other day a
different one that was 97 that i
referenced earlier we're actually doing
some research right now in the timeshare
industry ramsey research our research
arm and i
can't wait to get to report that to you
guys it's gonna be amazing
uh our guys are they know how to do the
actual research it'll be it'll be
straight now it won't just be let's
confirm dave's opinion now they actually
get real solid statistical evidence of
exactly what is going on in the
marketplace we do it for all kinds of
things
and around the money space and where we
get we see the consumer getting screwed
wholesale like this then we uh we want
to step in and find out what's really
happening because see people like hilton
are buying
diamond
and these executives that made all this
money all these years
are getting a real payday when hilton
comes in and buys that company out
so this is uh this is ding ding for them
they are ringing the bell at the bar
like they do when they get a tip
yeah
and it's i got a lot of zeros on it it's
amazing how much money those guys are
made off of you
andrew's in indianapolis hi andrew
welcome to the ramsey show tell me your
story
hi dave how are you great how can we
help
um yeah a couple of years ago um
probably
2013. i know 2014 i'm sorry
we my wife and i went to tennessee on a
time fair
that my sister-in-law and brother-in-law
gave us for our anniversary along with
our two very little kids
and um so you were using their week
yes sir we were using third week
in the gatlinburg or pigeon forge area
where in tennessee
uh
yeah it's got time sure crawling all
over it like termites
okay yes it does
and uh so we had uh my daughter was
three at the time my son was probably
maybe one and a half two at the oldest
and they told us oh it'll be just a 30
45 minute meeting or so and i kind of
rolled my eyes it's been like i've heard
this before but okay we'll we'll bite
the bull we already told you no but okay
we'll just you know they trick you with
that little gift or so
and uh what was the gift
what was the gift to get you into the
meeting
uh you know what it must have not been
that big of a deal because i don't
remember it actually okay uh i just
remember
it wasn't 30 minutes how long were you
in there
uh we were there for five and a half
hours
very little children
yes
um and at the one point or so so
the salesperson he was very nice very
nice and as soon as we started saying no
and he started realizing we weren't
interested
it flipped on a dime and he became the
most hateful person to us
he even called over his manager
and the manager got really angry with us
or so at the time my three-year-old she
was getting very fussy and he kind of
gave her a very dirty look at the and
i'm very normally a very quiet reserved
person or so my wife said that uh
it looked like i went i'm kind of
blacked out and i got up i said don't
you ever talk to my child like that ever
again looked at my wife said grab the
kids we are leaving i said if you bar me
from this thing i will not hesitate to
call the local authorities
wow
so you walked out it was a very
i'm sorry what so after five and a half
hours you walked out after they were
rude to you and finally
call it called down your kid
yes yeah you remember the company name
uh
no it uh the place we were staying at it
was blue green it was that's the company
of them yeah blue green is number four
um they're the number four largest one
and they they get more complaints oh my
god what a horrible company
wow yeah
oh my gosh
well there it is folks this is the time
share
industry
if you look up scum in the dictionary
you'll see their picture
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice can coleman ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
proximity principle is my co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
sarah is going to start us off this hour
in saratoga springs new york hi sarah
how are you
hi dave hi ken how are you
great how can we help
great um my husband and i are on data
step 3b
and we just closed on a house and we
were wondering how soon after we moved
into the house should we restart the
retirement again
well what do you think
i think about three to four months so we
can get used to the new budget in the
house but my husband feels anxious that
we haven't been putting it into
retirement and he wants to start it as
soon as possible yeah why would you wait
um just because the house payment and
house expenses are a little bit
different than what it is in our
apartment so i just wanted to get a
better handle on
what it's actually going to be per month
well you want to know
they gave you the payment amount at the
closing
true
what is it you're going to discover
i guess of like repairs and stuff like
that you just bought the house does it
need repairs
it's just like a new furnace it's like a
25 year old furnace so they suggested
um replacing it soon so we were going to
do that within the first couple months
okay get some bids on a furnace
okay so here's the thing okay
you you you should not have all of these
unknowns
and then once you don't have the
unknowns then that tells you when you
can start the retirement or should start
the retirement but i'm with your husband
i've got an urgency to get going on it
but i don't want to start your
retirement and then finance a furnace
so you know
i know but the balance is we got to
figure out how we're going to pay for
this furnace right
and so go ahead and get you know we know
what the payment house payment is
and uh shouldn't be hard to pull up the
electric bill you can get copies of that
from the former owner or even ask the
utility company they'll give you the
history on that so you have to lay your
budget out within a few dollars and then
you say then you get three bids on the
furnace and you go okay we're going to
spend x number of dollars on a furnace
and so that's going to mean we start the
retire we start retirement back after
the furnace is saved and that's going to
be here you ought to be able to lay all
of this out but but the idea we're going
to kick the can down the road for vague
unknowns that you should search out the
answer to is not a good plan
okay does that make sense to you
total sense yeah so go ahead and just
dial it in and if you get dialed in
you're okay ken yeah and you know one
other thing i'd say there is
who's they and let's get two or three
veys to look at that furnace and say do
we need to replace it now or do we think
it's got six months to your life go
ahead and save up for it get the quote
of what it's going to cost get three
four quotes and save it up but i i've
been scared before dave i remember when
i was a new homeowner and i all you need
to do this you need to do that well you
need to do this well do we really yeah
that's all you're still going to save up
for it prepare for it stinking thing
might last five years it could be the
efficiency on it too would be worth
going ahead and doing it but you also
want to catch it on seasonality that's
true meaning you don't want to you don't
want to do a replacement when
uh there's a line of people out the door
doing replacements because because the
season changed right that's correct you
want to do it in the off season where
they're catching when they're not
working and they give you a good deal
yeah and so the timing on it would be a
good idea too but you're right
you can go ahead and save up and be
ready for
executing on a certain timing or just be
ready when the thing lays down to fix it
at that point
anthony's with us anthony is in tampa
florida hi anthony welcome to the ramsay
show
hey dave such an honor to chat with you
how you doing you do how can we help
um just wondering on
which baby step can we start updating
kitchen updating pool
uh that kind of thing
well we teach folks to not do anything
until they're through baby step three
out of debt okay and have your emergency
fund in place because updating the
kitchen is not an emergency so you need
your emergency fund in place and be out
of debt first
now then at the point that you're at
baby steps four five and six you move
from intense
meaning not doing anything except those
things to intentional
and intentional means that there's some
other stuff in our life we're going to
do while we're doing retirement kids
college and paying extra on the house
but we're also going on vacation buy new
couch update the kitchen do the pool
whatever those things get woven into the
budget at that point of course paying
cash for them and but um
right there's a different rhythm there
ken in those uh three in four five six
yeah i like the distinction between
intense and then intentional you know
okay look we just talked about this a
previous caller we've got some real
expenses what would we consider higher
priority what's lower priority what's
just well we'd really like to do it but
it's really not going to affect our life
negative or positive one way or the
other and i think that's the
intentionality that you're speaking to
and i gotta tell you that's really
helped us from time to time go well i
want this but we don't need this good
distinction
the king coleman show is broadcast on 75
plus radio stations sirius xm and as a
podcast
every day he is helping folks with their
careers with their jobs with their
promotions
with uh finding their dream with finding
work that matters and plugging in every
day does that recruiters spend an
average of 7.4 seconds on an initial
resume screening gosh that's probably
double what i spend
and uh it's never been more difficult
for your resume to stand out among the
sea of participants and that's why we uh
ken created a six easy to use resume
templates to get you noticed uh there
are a whole 9.99
six of them and these are instructions
for building your resume the 10 do's and
don'ts of job applications text resume
to 33 789 you can get dialed in on that
resume two three three
seven
eight nine and of course you can follow
ken on the ken coleman show on
facebook ken coleman on instagram making
coleman show on youtube he's everywhere
helping people with their careers
including here today to help you if you
want to talk careers jump in at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
triple eight eight two five five
two two five
kelsey says in my office there's a job
opening that would be considered a
promotion what can i do to show my boss
i'm qualified yeah i love this i sit
down with them uh after we've looked at
the actual job description and make sure
you are qualified you just don't want to
be qualified in this uh particular
question it's all right we want to sit
down if you've got the qualifications
and go hey i'm really interested in this
opportunity here's why don't just lead
with qualifications lead with enthusiasm
see this is what a leader wants to know
they want to know not just that you're
qualified but you're raising your hand
not just for a promotion for you but
because you are really really deeply
excited about this opportunity to grow
yourself by adding more value to the
company they're going to go for
enthusiasm some passion more than just
qualification and lay it out there i'm
really interested i want the shot what
can i do to get the shot well man coach
that's it but hunger right not with an
attitude of hey give me the thing i'm
the guy that you're supposed to put in
the game no i want the shot coach put me
in coach i'll prove it that's it i'll
prove it hunger humility
i got it
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verses
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five you jump in we'll
talk about your life and your money
on the stage the debt-free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions is benjamin
and josefa hi guys how are you thank god
we're good how are you
better than i deserve my friend where do
you live we're from philadelphia
pennsylvania oh cool welcome to
nashville and all the way here to do a
debt-free scream how much have you paid
off
73 046
very good and how long did this take you
28 months all right and your range of
income during that time uh 136 000 to
143. very good what do you do for a
living i work in sales
what do you sell
so we help pharmaceutical companies with
a quality system okay cool
i'm a stay-at-home mom wonderful yeah
okay very good what kind of debt was
your 73 000 student loans
yay
you got rid of sallie mae yeah we're so
happy to say goodbye to that toss her
out in the street where she belongs
i love it so what's how long you guys
been married
almost six years okay
so two years ago in some change
something changed what
happened well um
we have been on a financial journey
since the beginning of our marriage
and
actually it's funny because um when
right before i got married with
tabinyamen my friend was telling me
about this snowball thing i'm like oh
okay guess i guess that that is bad so
we were actually living in brooklyn new
york
and we moved to philly philadelphia with
the intention of buying a home
so we for we decided for one year we'll
rent and then we started our home search
a year later
and none of the homes looked really
great
um
and then one day benjamin comes home and
i'll let him finish the story so i came
home because i had a long conversation
with a couple of friends of mine and
realized that we're about to undertake
getting a house and we still have over
70 thousand dollars worth of debt left
and that doesn't really make sense if
you have to replace a roof that's gonna
cost you ten thousand dollars and we're
never to set up a financially successful
life for our families so we had a pretty
difficult conversation for the next
couple of days we bought the uh most of
your books started religiously listening
to the podcast and then decided okay
we're going to do this and we set out on
a trek from there to knock out the next
the rest of the debt how did you run
into our stuff
i had a friend i have a couple of
friends in philadelphia that are strong
adherents
and so it was a lengthy conversation you
know
we it was hard to get not be on the
house buying train like everybody else
and say you know we were in the same
boat as everybody else and it kind of
came to the realization that this
doesn't make sense right now yeah very
cool very cool well congratulations you
guys i'm proud of you very well done who
were your uh biggest cheerleaders
cheering you on along the way
our family
they're definitely supportive and it was
really good to have friends kind of in
the same boat as us like living the dave
ramsey lifestyle and having that yeah
fun so you got a bunch of people doing
it oh yeah
very cool so i gotta i gotta ask you buy
the books you start listening daily to
the show and so you're really starting
to soak all this in what were some of
the first big steps maybe a big momentum
starter for you to get started on this
debt snowball and really get some
traction what'd you guys do
but we had to make the first difficult
choice to take all the money that we had
put to the house and throw it into that
yeah
that's hard and so that was that was
hard i mean honestly a process of
becoming comfortable with your lot we
had to decide for the next three years
or however long it's going to take we're
going to live in an apartment instead of
where everybody else is going to buy
houses we're going to be comfortable and
and and make do with what we have and be
happy with it and so i mean the first
biggest step was just the the mental
state of being willing to to do that and
kind of getting on the same page i mean
once you're on the same page it's a lot
easier yeah um and so that was really
the first part of the process yeah i
have to admit it took me a little bit to
get
onto that page but once i did i was
definitely happy
um well you were on the house train oh
yeah it was really disappointing to say
no to
yeah but um
the budget part was really important but
as you can tell from when uh benjamin
mentioned his range of income not much
changed it was more of a mindset that
had to change you know we were dealing
with a similar budget
we just had to differentiate between the
things that we
needed and the things that we wanted to
have and we'd like to have and the
impulse buys that we wanted to do so
that was definitely a difficult mindset
change yeah that's a big deal that's a
big deal
so how's it feel now that you're free
it's it's actually i listen to the show
a lot of times the typical answers are
and it's true for us too it's liberating
it's freeing it's like a weight off your
shoulders a friend of mine made an
interesting comment to me
who started the ramsey journey for
himself which is that i you know and we
felt the same way i thought that freedom
really is the ability to buy what i want
but it's not really because the freedom
is actually the ability to make
unencumbered choices
and freedom really lives kind of in that
mindset where you have a structure you
have you know you have the baby steps
you have a plan and you find freedom
within that when you don't have the plan
you don't have a structure you actually
end up buying a bunch of stuff you don't
need you end up spending more than you
actually make and so it's actually the
true freedom is within that structure
and once you get to the end of it then
you really have the ability to make
unencumbered choices okay so that's you
know true freedom hey man that's good
yeah i mean that's like i'm gonna take
the next segment you should
that's a great great visual too to that
word that's a 50 cent word but the
reality is
it's there's no strings it's nothing
holding you back yeah it's a beautiful
beautiful illustration powerful now you
brought friends with you who are the
friends just off camera over here well
we got our family oh your family three
kids
um and also my father
and my brother and his family also oh
very good quite quite a family affair
then yeah brought the cheering gallery
very good good
well we've got a copy of the legacy
journey for you and a copy of the total
money makeover you can pass those along
enjoy them yourself and oh here they
come i love it what are the babies names
and ages so this is
mendel he's eight months this is
endogetous she's two and a half and this
is ellie as her lady's five fabulous
they look fun oh they are very cool very
cool i love it well congratulations you
guys thank you very very well done all
right benjamin and josefa
73 000
paid off in 28 months making 136 to 143
they are now unencumbered they are they
are debt free count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one thank god we're debt-free
i love it
that's fun look at those babies they're
cute
very well done that's a great family and
great story completely free
you know there's a lot said in that
interview with them
this idea that
i can just
i
it was a decision and once we made the
decision
all the drama goes away
and it funny where all the drama and anc
are comes from is
not
staying with the decision yes
you know proverbs says a double-minded
man yes is unstable in all his ways
and we add drama to our lives when we
don't stick with okay we're going to do
this we're going to stick with it
then all the other stuff's off the table
and it just all of the emotion and the
psychology and the drama and stuff
starts to melt away doesn't it it really
does in fact the rest of that scripture
talks about the the analogy of driven
like the waves and the wind of the sea
you know just this back and forth back
and forth and committing to the decision
and then managing the decision once the
decision is made we manage our behavior
based on the decision i'll tell you one
other thing that that i heard dave that
i thought was really cool for those of
you that listen to the show and you're
debt free and you're still part of this
amazing community of people
that was it was a friend who was on
their own debt free journey that said
whoa slow down on that house purchase
slow down and a friend
said hey
maybe consider this and because of that
friend and group of friends they
discovered financial peace don't forget
that as you're going through journey and
you're getting freedom and hope to share
that with others you may be the lifeline
that they needed that'll move things
along for sure very good stuff well done
they're heroes they're awesome love it
love it love it
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
ken coleman ramsey personality is my
co-host today chrissy wright our co-host
in crime
another ramsey personality has launched
the pre-sale of her brand new book take
back your time the guilt-free guide
to life balance for years christie was
stretched way too thin she has a mom of
three with a full-time career she
realized something had to change and she
took a long hard look at her life and
she figured out why she felt overwhelmed
and why she felt over committed all the
time and she figured out that balance is
about doing the right things at the
right
time
the new book is take back your time
the guilt-free guide to life balance if
you pre-order right now while it's on
sale it comes out in september you get
fifty dollars worth of free bonus items
that includes the audiobook read by
christy the e-book access to the take
back your time live stream and a lot
more so all you do is go to
ramseysolutions.com pre-order your copy
of christy's new book take back your
time and get it done today ken we've got
a big announcement coming up next week
on your new stuff oh exciting can't tell
about it but yeah i know it's like a
secret big secret not really i need to
stop or dave's got this little button he
pushes shock me right here would be
great television now they they've got a
button in there they push they it's the
eject button and i go out through the
roof when i launch something
sooner than it's supposed to launch i
get launched look how much enjoyment
james and kelly's faces of the idea of
they're just licking their chops
they're proverbial chops
yes indeed ah jared is in irvine
california hi jared welcome to the
ramsay show
hey mr randy how's it going better than
i deserve sir what's up in your world
hey so i was just calling with a
question for you
i'm looking to get some guidance as to
whether or not i should
sell my house
and move up or if i should stay where
i'm at with the smaller space i'll give
you a little background real quick
uh we're in a two bedroom condo right
now and we have two small children so
the boys are sharing a room
and we're gonna be trying for a third
here real soon so that's why i'm having
the debate of
do i sell in this awesome seller's
market and try to move up and maybe
stretch our budget a little thin or do i
just suck it up and try to cram three
kids in a two-bedroom condo yeah
are you out of debt except the condo
uh yes we're in baby steps four five and
six good okay
when you make the move up are you gonna
do it on a 15-year fixed where the
payment's no more than a fourth of your
take-home pay
uh yes that's the plan
if you can do that i don't have anything
my question too
just
trying to figure out how much exactly i
can afford without
you know stretching too far 25 of your
take-home pay is a payment on a 15-year
fixed rate and if you do that you know
you're not going to be stretched too
thin you're going to be okay
the problem gets in is because let me
tell you the mortgage company will
approve you for almost twice that much
almost twice that much
to where
as much
in other words they'll move you over to
a 30 from a 15
and then they'll jam that ratio all the
way as high as they can jam it up in the
high 30s uh up close to 40 percent of
your take-home pay
and uh and then you're on a 30-year
mortgage and now you're owned by them
which is the goal instead what we're our
goal is to get you into that mortgage
and get you into that house and get you
back out of that mortgage and that's why
we do a 15-year fix let's get it paid
off in 10 then and have a game plan to
get at it but it does sound like you
need to move dude you got kids coming
out everywhere
it's just like
you got you got a whole stack of them
there man the two boys in the room you
can manage that
third one for a pair the third one
changes that whole equation yeah yeah
and it's it's obviously getting tight in
there but um yeah you just can't use the
old i'm in california excuse because you
know the math still works in california
um in spite of what some of the
politicians say math still works in
california so it's still what has to
happen there
hey open phones at
two five 825-5225 next in austin texas
hi tiffany how are you
hi mr ramsey i'm a new listener and a
colleague has suggested that i i call in
today okay
so recently i've been really focusing on
paying off my debt with my husband and
this morning i was um served um papers
from a student loan that i thought was
no longer my responsibility um it was a
private student loan that i had gotten
out years ago with my
deceased grandfather
um i have
at the time we couldn't afford to pay it
back when my grandfather passed away
newly married and then i started
disputing it on my credit report on both
transunion and equifax and each time i
disputed it it came back that it was not
my debt
and it has since come off all of my
credit reporting over the last three to
four years
it did i did notice whenever i got
served this morning i went and checked
and it was on my equifax report
um but i'm just not sure what to do with
this thing i've never been sued or
anything like that and that kind of
scares you doesn't it
yeah i'm a little bit emotional today so
i told my husband i'm gonna call i don't
want to cry my mom just passed away a
few months ago so i'm like i'm gonna cry
that's okay i'm sorry
so how much is the debt
so the random thing is there's actually
two of them but they are only sending it
for one it's uh twelve thousand nine
hundred thirty dollars and eighty cents
okay
well here's the equation
if you
signed a contract
saying that you owe the debt when you
took it out with your grandfather
then you are liable whether it's on your
credit bureau report or not does not
affect your legal liability
you can have something that is never on
your credit bureau report and you're
legally liable because you signed a
contract saying you would pay it
if however your grandfather signed it
and you're listed as the person who got
the money for college but you did not
sign the agreement
then you are not liable and you will
need an attorney
so we don't know based on what you've
told me do you have any documents from
any of this
yeah i'm looking at it it does have me
as signature of borrower and then it has
my grandfather's signature of co-signer
okay so you're looking at the actual
loan agreement not the lawsuit
i'm looking at the lawsuit they have
several exhibits okay and one of the
exhibits is the original loan document
correct and it has you as the borrower
it is you as the borrower okay
well i'm sorry you're liable
you signed up tomorrow
how old were you when you signed that
um oh six
i can't even do that math right now uh
23. okay
okay you're you're over 18 so you're
liable
okay i'm not an attorney but that's the
correct answer all right when you sign a
loan document as the borrower that means
you're liable to pay it does that make
sense
yes so here's what we're gonna do they
say twelve thousand bucks you all have
any money
we can no how much money do you have
do you have any money
save right now i think our savings
account maybe has 1500
in it okay what can you scrape together
beyond that
um
my next big check will be in november
and so i'll have an additional ten
thousand dollars
okay uh
so you have a debt of twelve thousand
dollars that's what they're suing you
for correct
okay
so i'm and and this is how many years
ago
from 2006
2006 15 years
okay
so yeah i would call them and say i
don't have any money
i'm broke i just got served i didn't
even realize i was liable until i read
this exhibit
uh i do have fifteen hundred dollars if
you will accept that as settlement in
full
we can settle this today
they probably won't take that
but you probably can get it for about 25
cents on the dollar
not 10 cents on the dollar so if you
could scrape together another 1500 bucks
you probably can settle this and for
about 3 000 bucks
if you can get them to agree to that on
the phone
you get that in writing you do not give
them electronic access to your checking
account and then you wire them the money
directly or you send them a money order
or a prepaid debit card or something
that does not interfere with your
regular
monies
but scrape together a couple of thousand
bucks here two to three thousand dollars
i think you can talk them into taking
that as a settlement in full
get it in writing
before you send it to them and do not
let them into your personal checking
account as a part of the deal
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage troy and holly are with
us hey guys how are you awesome
welcome where do you guys live we're
from goshen indiana ocean south bend
area yes all right i think i see a notre
dame thing on here yeah yeah i didn't
know if i needed to hide that or is
we allow almost anybody in here
welcome so you're here to do a debt-free
scream how much have you paid off we
paid off 65 000 in 30 months very good
and your range of income during that
time actually went from fifty two
thousand to forty eight thousand oh down
okay yeah there's a story here huh yeah
there's a little bit of story i'm a high
school math teacher and i was a varsity
boys basketball coach for eight years
and um actually decided to step down
during our debt free um journey just
felt as you'll see a little bit our kids
and our family was growing we have five
kids and just felt like it was time to
take a step back and it was cool to see
god work out um the details of when we
actually took less income and had some
other things pop up during that time
very cool good for you what kind of debt
was the 65 000 it was all our house oh
you paid off your house
we're looking at weird people yes you
are how old are you guys i'm 37 and my
wife is 36. wow
that's awesome paid for house man you're
so weird what's this house worth
uh i would say in the market we're in i
say 180 to 200 somewhere in there i'll
go with that very good
man that's whack you're not even 40 and
you have a paid for house tell us about
this journey what happened two and a
half years ago made you guys lean into
this well it doesn't it really starts 16
years ago so 16 years ago next month
will be our anniversary our 16 year
anniversary and um like this is a god
story we're we're on our honeymoon uh 16
years ago driving to tennessee and
driving down to florida later on and
back in those days we didn't use our
phone to listen to podcasts and
everything we were using the old seek
and scan button on the radio
yeah it's amazing right and we're just
looking for some good music to listen to
and whatever and this guy comes on the
radio it's a talk show he's talking
about plastectomies he's talking about
baby steps uh he's talking about debt is
dumb cash's king and the paid off home
mortgage is taking the place of the bmw
as a status symbol of choice and it
caught me right away and i had never
heard of you before that and um i'm like
i'm i'm getting it so when we got back
home offer honeymoon we did the old
google search and found out that you
were on in our area just never knew it
and so started listening to the show and
um for 16 years we've just been slowly
slowly making good decisions and um
it ends in this very cool very cool so
you whittled away and walked all the way
through the baby steps yeah essentially
when we we had bought we had bought in a
used car right before we got married um
i put it on on the payments because we
didn't know any better right and right
away i hear you talking about that's not
okay and so uh once i graduated college
and we were able to um you know have my
teacher income and so on we started
attacking uh the car and then my student
loans at that point we've been debt free
um from that probably 12 plus years and
then i knew at some point we wanted to
get you know the house that was the big
one and so 30 months ago is where the
story comes in 30 months ago it was my
birthday i would have been turning 35
and i just we had 65 000 left on the
morgan i looked there and said i want
this done by the time i'm 40. and we
literally took out some old construction
paper made a house that we colored in
every month the kids got involved in
that and that we put it on our bathroom
door and every month i just look forward
to getting that thing and that became
our motivation and um i said i want to
do before i'm 40 and i'm turning 38 next
month so it was just amazing to see to
see god work out the details on that
journey did you step away from coaching
yes yeah that's that's a sacrifice
i know a lot of coaches a lot of coaches
a lot of a lot of coaches that they
couldn't they couldn't conceive of not
being a coach and i can see that you you
love coaching first to step aside like
that to spend more time with the family
and that's a big sacrifice talk about
how that paid off and and where that
goes from there yeah um i think what
i've learned is in life
um whether i love coaching you know and
um
when i put in god's hands and and follow
even if it doesn't feel right or seem
right yeah you believe in his hands
things work out and um you know like
this summer i was able to coach my son's
little league next year i'll coach a
seventh grade basketball team instead of
the varsity basketball team that my son
is on and being able to still do what i
love in a different avenue with less
pressure less time and still being
around my family so follow up to that so
i'm reading into what you said so you
stepped back from coaching that's where
the pay went down correct but then you
said god brought some other pay in
um that that that would just be my
teaching salary that i mentioned but i i
work at a golf course in the summers and
pick up odds and ends and um again
here's another god thing so uh the year
that i i quit high school coaching um
had no intent of going to the college
game and labor day i quit in april and
in labor day weekend i get a call from a
college coach saying i need an assistant
i'm desperate will you help me out and
wasn't planning on that but i did do
college coaching for a year and ended up
financially being blessed more than what
the high school yeah was so just to see
that's cool a lot of people don't know
that part of the story wow pretty cool
well done
how's it feel holly did not have a
payment
it feels amazing
[Laughter]
freeing what's the first big thing you
guys are going to do now that you don't
have a house payment
i think we want to save up for a family
cruise maybe that's a good plan yep i
like that one and just just that for me
like we've said no so many times you
know on this just to the little things
just i look forward to the yeses that i
can give my kids now
that's powerful
yeah no no means yes later that's what
it means if you live like no one else
later you can live and give like no one
else i love it very cool what do you
tell people the key to getting out of
debt is you've been on a long journey
here
um i would say just persistence and it
it seems like you'll never get there but
you do and one day you're just like wow
that just happened
that little that little construction
house up there on the door is done yes
it is and and i want to i want to take a
special shot to my wife because we
haven't talked about what she does um
she has the harder job she stays home
right and and she does some
homeschooling with our kids and we have
foster care and adoption in our story as
well yeah and she's the real hero um you
know i'm off able to do what i want with
teaching and coaching and doing those
things but when she stays home and takes
care of the family um and is able and
and financially we have been on the same
page all of our marriage i don't think
we've ever had a money fight and just to
have a wife that
is on the same page and um the day that
like
the amount that we owed in the house
minus our emergency fund that day that
we could we had the money to do it like
lump sum let's finish this baby off i
get home from school i'm like babe like
it's there we can take it out and the
emergency fund is still there and i'm
just kind of waiting for that day and
seeing what she would say and like
instantly she's like we'll get to the
bank right now like let's go and so just
to have a teammate that has been like
that has just been awesome yeah she's a
real hero well done you guys well done
very proud of y'all who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
yeah i was gonna say it's mostly been
ourselves but we definitely have people
that
are supportive and they're definitely
happy when we talk about it
um so we've been blessed that's good
very cool we got a copy of the legacy
journey for you that's what you've done
you've changed this whole family tree
financially well done and also a copy of
the total money makeover for you to give
away and start someone on their journey
that i like that crazy guy on the radio
all those years ago as you're driving
through tennessee go figure
very very cool good for you guys so you
brought the kiddos with you let's put
them into the shot and give me their
names and ages
so kylie is almost 14.
drew is
12. jeremiah is 11.
brayden is eight and cameron is he's
almost five but he's four all right very
cool so good to have you guys a good
looking family well done well done well
done all right it's troy and holly and
the tribe from south bend indiana area
65 000 paid off in 30 months that's the
house and everything making 52 down to
48 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream all right you guys ready
to god be all the glory honor and praise
three
two one
[Applause]
high fives all around dave that's
awesome that's how i do love it that's
how coach does it at his house
i love it
very very cool stuff absolutely amazing
yeah
good-looking family yeah oh it's so fun
there's something uh about having the
whole family celebrate yeah you can see
a lot of teamwork between that husband
and wife certainly with the kids getting
it that's a special moment that wasn't
just a performance there they're
genuinely happy the way they're giving
themselves away
through foster care adoption and just
they've set a course dave that as you
know
it's going to be hard to keep that
family's legacy down it's only 50 000
bucks a year they don't have a house
payment no sir they don't have a house
payment yeah this is pretty incredible
yeah i mean they really
have pulled off something here that's a
pretty on a teacher's salary for yeah
there it is again those teachers they
pop up everywhere i love it i love it
very well done that puts this hour of
the ramsey show in the books good hour
ken good hour james childs our producer
kelly daniel our associate producer and
phone screener i am dave ramsey your
host and we'll be back
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode in the
podcast show notes section or head to
theramsieshow.com
thanks for listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice ken coleman ramsey personality is
my co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five marie starts
off this hour in washington dc hi marie
how are you
i'm great thank you how are you doing
better than i deserve what's up
um my husband and i don't know when we
should buy a house
we're on baby steps four and five we're
renting right now but my husband's
company is relocating us next june
and we we don't know when to buy our
three thoughts were
start looking in the fall
before we move maybe buy
so we have plenty of time and we're not
pressured and then we have a place to
land once we move
the second is either moving with our
in-laws for a couple of months next june
and then buy
and then the third option
is maybe move
in june rent for six months and then in
that six-month period
um buy a house but we don't know what we
should do
um my husband doesn't really want to
rent anymore because he just wants to
start building equity
um
why do you have to start looking in the
fall
to buy a house by june
that sounds fairly inefficient to me
well i think he just wants to
see what's available because the
market's so hot and if there's something
that we like
we would just rather buy it
and then have our in-laws who live there
sort of
watch it and go for if we have
construction so you're going to just
going to piss away six months worth of
house payments
you know we would pay the the i know
you're just burning it you just put 100
bills in the middle of the kitchen table
and set them on fire
okay for what
why can't you i mean let me tell you
what a normal procedure would be if i'm
gonna move in june i make a trip over in
february and start looking
okay and close something like may
okay and then i move entered in june
okay
cause she's thinking of like going to on
a house hunting trip and
like seeing a few places in october i
know why
if you want to go over there just for
the fun of it that's fine but you don't
need to buy a house in october that
you're not moving into until june it
doesn't make any sense at all
so we wouldn't necessarily buy right in
october like just to look and maybe
something comes up in january
okay bye in may start looking and buy in
may
and move in in june
that way you're not paying a house
payment for a house that's just sitting
there because you got the itch
okay
and you're paying rent by the way back
where you are right
i know i know i guess this is also what
has been thinking that's what like a lot
is happening all at once so if we can
have a place to land then it's not
okay you do whatever you want to do but
that's weird all right yeah and i would
just say option three is a viable option
i get that your hubs doesn't wanna rent
but you know there's a lot of things i
don't wanna do that i still do because
they're the best thing to do and if
you're stressed out about it go rent
and get your bearings when stacy and i
moved back here seven years ago we
rented for a year because we had kids we
want to make sure that it was the best
school situation the best neighborhood
so we took our time and we had a place
to land because we were renting and then
we're able to take our time and walk
uh really wisely through the process uh
in your position i don't know why you
wouldn't consider renting other than he
doesn't want to yeah but either way
dave's answer is just as good
it's okay i mean you can rent for six
months and buy during that time
or you can uh just move in may
yeah right that's when you're moving
anyway it's me
so buy a house moving me
and you know and so and then dial back
out of that that means i might start
looking in march or april
and with a you know with a possession of
sometime in may
upon the closing that kind of a thing
that's a fairly normal process yeah
there's fear all over that
to where you said the same thing three
different ways and there's fear that's
covering that up not picking on her but
it's fear and part of it's going well
the the market we gotta move now i got
news for you based on what i'd be better
off you'll be better off to buy the
market is i'm not saying it's peaking
but it's not gonna keep going up up up
the way it has been i think everything
is calming down it really is this it was
a covet blip and it's calming down it's
not it's going to continue real estate
goes up in value it's a good investment
that's right but it's you know the idea
that it's going to double between now
and may is ridiculous it's not going to
denver's an expensive market anyway yeah
but um it's not gonna double you're
gonna be okay marie buy a house
when you need
the house
not six months before
that's unwise
that was a gentler way of saying it
gabriel is in canada hi gabriel how are
you
hey guys you're awesome
cool how can we help jim
i have a question uh so i'm looking to
get married next year
um to my girlfriend
but uh her dad's um
very considerate with like uh making
sure that i could support her good um
like financially good can you i think um
uh well she was in switzerland um
so i kind of need to find a job there
first but the plan was to
save up twenty five thousand dollars and
then with that money we can get married
move in
uh rent a place
um so i was just wondering what you guys
think about that plan
why do you need twenty five thousand
dollars to go to switzerland
no like for the wedding um why it's
funny
yeah okay are you working you got it you
can you got the money to do that
uh as of now i have around 11 000 but
yeah i'm working okay so you're well on
your way then i think well all you're
gonna need is a job that makes as much
as you make now
in the area of switzerland
right okay
and do you think twenty five thousand
dollars enough for all those things
for a wedding and what else
wedding rent like first months rent we
want two months expenses we basically
want to go into a debt free yeah
yeah i mean it'd be great to have your
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses if you want to have those
dialed in and you know where they're
going to be
that'd be wonderful and pay cash for the
wedding um it all matters you know it's
not enough if your wedding's thirty
thousand but it's plenty if your wedding
is ten thousand
yeah that's so you know it's all about
the wedding budget as to whether that 25
works or not i don't know where how much
of that you're going to spend on the wet
on the wedding so
um i like the conversation that you're
having with her dad uh that means you're
a young man of honor
and um her dad is um
stretching you and her to do this the
right way that's cool it is it's it's
good to see that and you know a real
quick thing here i would adjust the i
would adjust the wedding budget based on
if you're going to be hustling to get to
25 let's adjust that budget you know i
mean you can always do uh great trips as
we get together in marriage we're
debt-free we stay debt-free we live like
no one else uh the cost of weddings dave
can get really outrageous quickly i've
heard the rumor
[Laughter]
this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well if you're struggling
with debt
you know what it's like to be scared you
know it's like to be overwhelmed where
you can't even think straight i've been
there too
you don't have to live like that anymore
when you pay off all your debt as fast
as possible you will never have that
kind of stress in your life again
and you can do this here's where you
start
millions and millions of people have
gone through
and gotten out of debt by going through
financial peace
university
they've learned how to pay off their
debt take control of their money and you
can stream all nine lessons right now
and you get some extra support by going
through the class with others
and the only way to get financial peace
university
is with a ramsey plus membership you can
get rid of the death that's holding you
back and in the cycle of worry and
stress start the free trial
of ramsay plus by texting trial 233
789 text trial two three three
seven
eight nine our question that it comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and with new
promos they run all the time you'll save
even more use the promo code ramsay to
get the best possible deal today's
question comes from alex in alabama he
writes that i'm single 25 years old in
the military and on baby step 3b with
170 000 in investments i've always
wanted to be a pilot and i'm halfway
through the process of getting my
commercial license if i stay in the
military it will take me three more
years to get the license and
qualifications to be a pilot it will
only take four months if i pursue it
full time i'm afraid the aviation
industry will recover soon and i'll miss
the employment wave so i want to get the
license asap to de-risk my situation
burning bridges in the military and
taking a step backwards career-wise
is holding me back should i leave the
military now to pursue flying full-time
okay there's so much here dave first of
all i'm afraid that the aviation
industry will recover sooner and i'll
miss the employment wave that's not true
there's always going to be a need for
pilots that's a false narrative that's
creating some unnecessary pressure i
also have questions about burning
bridges in the military i don't know why
in the world you would need to to burn
bridges if you're leaving honorably and
you're leaving from the military to go
into the marketplace to pursue a future
you don't have to burn bridges if you're
a jerk and you leave the wrong way
that's the only way you're burning a
bridge so don't quite understand that
you have two options here if you want to
take your time and financially it's more
viable for you to finish out the three
years
or your stay in the military and then
get the license that's fine too but if
you're 25 you've got some good
investments and you've planned for this
financially to go full time for four
months you got to have living expenses
you don't want to go backwards
financially for the four months that you
got to go full on to get the uh pilot's
license so i don't think there's a bad
decision if it's me i'm planning for
this and i'm gonna go for the four-month
option and i'm not gonna look back but
you can't let fear
of something that's not real hold you
back here dave
now what i can't tell from the email is
if he has served his that's what i'm
clear on yeah his time that he has yeah
promised the military yeah and if he's
you know you can't just walk out that's
not and i think that's what he's
alluding to that's not burning the
bridge that's just not an option yeah
you can't you can't just walk away you
said i'm we're gonna serve four years
you're gonna serve four years that's
correct you know so you know or whatever
it is you signed up for what was your
your tour and so now when your time is
up
if you're referring to burning bridges
because somebody's gonna get their
feelings hurt that you left the military
well that's on them that's not on you
you just don't be a jerk and you say
i've enjoyed my time here and i've
enjoyed serving my country and i'm gonna
move on with my career if your time is
up so if you can leave without doing
something illegal or breaking a contract
and be done in four months that's what
you should do yeah but not because the
whole aviation industry is going to
evaporate in the next three years if
it's going to evaporate in the next
three years why are you going into it in
the first place
that's a dumb plan you know it's like
you're going to get the one job that's
left and they're never you're never
going to need to right another thing
ever they're going to hire everybody and
you're gonna be the last one no that's
that's that's a completely false
narrative yeah but uh but again it has
to do i can't tell from what i can't i
don't know what burn bridges means here
yeah it's hard to say i'm assuming he
realizes you just can't walk from the
military
you would think you can't just show up
and ghost them you know like hey i'm out
i think i'm gonna get my two week notice
yeah i think that's the way that doesn't
work that way i don't think that's how
it works all right tyler's with us tyler
is in salt lake city hi tyler what's up
hey guys thanks for letting me join you
today sure how can we help
hey so i just kind of have a unique job
situation so we're in baby step four
five and six
and i'm a professor at a university and
so
they put 15
of
my income through a retirement account
every paycheck
they do free tuition for my kids
and our plan is to get the house paid
off in the next four years
but i wonder what's what's the
i guess what i should be doing in terms
of that four five and six in addition to
maybe
doing some remodels to the house that my
wife really wants
okay well baby step four is fifteen
percent
of your income going into retirement
right
okay and that gets you the full match
right
well so well they'll so they do that
without a match so they just they do 15
regard i don't put in any they put them
through well that's just that's just a
nice benefit okay that's wonderful but
you need to be putting
15
of your income
into retirement that's baby step four
okay you knew that you knew that was
might be step four right
yeah i knew that was the step four i
just thought well i've been listening to
you for five years and a few years ago
you when someone had a big retirement
like that you would say well maybe you
do five or seven percent and throw a
little more towards the house but lately
i've been hearing you say you know do
the full 15 no matter what they do
a big retirement you mean like the the
amount they're putting in or if you've
got a million dollars already in there
no so i have about a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars you don't have a big
retirement that's a little no no no
yeah yeah you're talking about the
amount they're putting in i i think the
only time i have said that and i
i
one of the few things i am is actually
consistent um
so uh i think the only times i have said
to lower it down to that to seven
percent or something
is um
not not based on how much they were
putting in but mandatory
placement like they require there are
some positions where they require you to
put 12 percent into a program that's
like a pension plan or something and
then do i need to put 15 more on top of
that no we back that off or or they're
going to furnish this or that so anyway
you can you can do whatever you want but
i would recommend you put 15 of your
income in and that you take care of kids
college and then you work to pay off
your house and remodel your house out of
the balance
and that's
you know that that's pretty consistently
yeah what we teach so hey thank you
robin is with us robin is in nashville
hey robin what's up
hi dave thank you so much for taking my
call i really appreciate it i will
listen to you for years and years okay
um
i'm cummering because i have an
interesting situation i've been married
for almost 25 years
um live about 10 hours away from our
in-laws and the rest of my entire
husband's family
they own a his parents being they own a
lake house
and they came to us recently asked if
we'd like to buy in um they own it
outright but they told us in the next
couple of years they would like us to
make a monthly payment
to keep it running
and then they would then turn it over to
us in about the year 2023.
my husband and i kind of sat down and
and did the math um
and decided to not do that good his
other two siblings opted in we opted out
good
um
but there's two there's two problems
there number one
um
we're the only weirdos that that left
the family and left the state and we're
also weird because we follow your plan
to a tea and are debt-free except for
our house
and you're 10 hours away from the lake
house so there's no reason to buy into
it
right
yeah but they see us having a lot of
money and so why wouldn't we because
it's such a small because we don't want
to and it's our money
correct yes exactly
and now they are going around the family
telling everyone that we have opted out
of our inheritance
well and i'm struggling how to explain
to them that's not inheritance i just
wouldn't
just let them do whatever they're going
to do i mean
they're just being butts
you can't make somebody not be a butt
so hurt your feelings though
but you didn't opt out of anything you
opted out of a dumb plan
good for you
and if they're not going to leave you
something because of that oh well that's
okay
move on with your life i mean it sort of
sad
people trying to control people
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage adam and aaron are with
us hey guys how are you good great
welcome so good to have you where do you
guys live mount vernon iowa all right
welcome to nashville so good to have you
and here to do a debt-free scream that's
right how much have you paid off we paid
off 266 thousand dollars
how long did this take took about 13
years okay and your range of income
during that time we started out about
uh 85 000 and went up to about 195. wow
nice what do y'all do for a living
i'm a manager release engineering team
uh at a software company
and my wife i teach second grade good
very cool
266 000 13 years that must mean you paid
off your house we did pay off
looking at weird people
i love it
how am i how old are you two
i'm 46 i'm 45.
and you did it before 50 years old that
is so weird
i love it what's this house worth
i think right now it's probably worth at
least 350 but it's hard to say very nice
good for you how's it feel to not have a
payment in the world so happy yeah
that's amazing well done
266 000 paid off 13 years so you just
been working the way you're supposed to
work it just having living life living
on a plan and knocking it out
so what what's the story of behind this
what got you started 13 years ago so 13
years ago i was on a business trip in
about 2008 and coming back and i wasn't
in control the radio um and your show
came on
um and i had never heard you before at
all but a lot of it was kind of speaking
to me and listened to that for probably
a solid hour on the way back and uh got
home and did uh
did the searches on the internet and
found uh found what your baby steps were
and i kind of followed that for a little
bit but we probably didn't kick it in
for another two or three years but
certainly uh we were headed that
direction anyway both of our parents are
very conservative i think the only thing
that would have been acceptable was a
car and a house payment but
we wanted to get out of all that um we
have four kids uh they're age 22 down to
uh 13 now
and so it's just kind of slow and steady
and and it was it was hard for us
particularly because
i think
you know you get into that that medium
income and we didn't have a lot to cut
out that um a lot of other families
might write we didn't have a lot of
traditional consumer debt to take out
the equation but
um so yeah it was a lot slow and steady
we i uh did fpu i facilitated that for
you guys a number of times over the
years and
we did it ourselves that gives you a
boost yeah it helped yeah
it's harder it's harder it's hard to not
do the things we teach when you are the
freaking teacher yeah yeah you have to
do it it's like it's like hypocritical
weird yeah if you don't i'm i don't
really do all right no that wouldn't
work yeah yep that very good i got to
ask you about your the promotion over
that 13-year period you go from 85 to
165. 95. oh what was it 190. oh i'm
sorry it could be my own writing 195. so
what what happened there what was that
journey i yeah i was i stayed home with
our kids when they were little um and
then i did open my own preschool and i
did that for a few years and i've done
in-home day care along the way to always
earn us some
extra money but then um i did start
teaching full time about nine years ago
um so
that was part of that so that that added
a big chunk of it and just you know good
yeah oh yeah no certainly i've i've
moved up i've been at the same company
for 24 years i worked for pearson
education and um i've had a very
successful career there i'm very happy
for it but yeah but she's the workhorse
right even when she was home with the
kids she was she was kicking butt
figuratively
in some cases literally
good very good you guys what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
um i would really like like adam said
you know we always spent conservatively
so
we probably jumped into our home
a little bit
ahead of schedule financially but it was
where we wanted to be and where we knew
we wanted to raise our family
so that kind of pushed us back a little
bit but it was just a slow steady
race but i am excited because we did say
some no's you know when you know other
people were doing vacations or you know
spending a little more frivolously um so
i am our youngest our oldest i'm sorry
just got married a couple of weeks ago
um and i'm excited for you know the next
chapter of our lives and be able to say
a few more yeses you know to
some of the fun things yeah that's fun
yeah you're in really good shape to do
that yeah you don't have any payments
right i love it
yeah
that's so funny i know you're a car guy
dave i uh i've driven a prius for over
10 years now and uh i have four younger
brothers that would say that was not the
manliest car on the planet but uh
um so we've
i and i've wanted a truck forever
forever and i've told her about it
forever i have a young nephew that that
would always ask me uncle adam when you
get in the truck when you get in your
truck and i for a while i told him uh
aaron said i can't get it and then i had
to take that back because she said
because it wasn't true um but
but finally uh last year with covid and
with a wedding on the horizon another
graduation on the horizon i did flip the
script and i i wanted to wait until
after the mortgage was paid off to get
it and i know that's really not your
principles and i've heard you speak that
a number of times and we decided to get
the truck last year and uh
and finish off the mortgage this year
that's cool good good for you that's a
normal thing that's good that's the way
it should go i like this you guys are
heroes well done you're free
you set yourself free i'm so proud of
you excellent excellent job well we've
got a copy of the legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
you're leaving a legacy to these kids
these weddings are starting to happen
next thing you know grand babies will be
coming along life is good man
and i'll go visit papa in his truck
there you go i like it it's good stuff
good stuff also a copy of the total
money makeover for you to give away and
pay it forward and get somebody started
on their journey as well so really good
job you guys excellent work and thanks
again for being coordinators as well
adam and aaron from the cedar rapids
iowa area
266 thousand dollars house and
everything
paid off in 13 years making 85 to 195.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
excellent job
absolutely incredible that is fabulous
that's how it's done
so what we're seeing ken over and over
and over again are these
what i'm now starting to call baby steps
millionaires the people that have
followed the baby steps
and
there they sit with a 350 000 paid for
home wow uh we don't have to we didn't
ask about their retirement accounts but
we know that during that 13 years that
they've also been
investing in the 401k because they were
following our steps precisely
so we know there's a chunk there and so
they might not be millionaires right
there today we didn't quiz them on that
but they're very close
and they're and they're yeah and by
their mid-40s they will be yeah or
they're in their mind they're in their
mid-40s by the time they hit actually
the every the the millionaire study that
we did the average millionaire that we
studied out of 10 000 almost 52. wow so
they're going to be right on that yeah
they're going to be right on that and
they're you know they're going to be get
their first million dollar net worth
with a paid for home and with a pile of
money in your 401k
following the baby steps and so we see a
lot of times it's about a third like you
got about a million and a half dollar
net worth you got about a 500 000 paid
for house and you got about a million in
your 401ks and your roth iras we see
that pop up all the time with these baby
steps millionaires it's uh uh but i and
it's really
it's not billionaires no if if you want
to be a billionaire
you really shouldn't use the baby steps
because you're not going to get there
ever oh that's right because a billion
is 1 000
million
so if you have ten thousand dollars
mathematically
on a ratio basis you are closer to being
a millionaire than a millionaire is to
being a billionaire
ah
yeah but everybody thinks of
millionaires as being like the same kind
of rich as billionaires millionaires
don't have private jets millionaires
don't drive 250 000 lamborghinis
millionaires don't have four extra
vacation homes those are things that
billionaires do
now if you want to be a billionaire you
need to use a different formula the baby
steps won't get you there in this
lifetime but if you want
one to 10 million dollars
and that's your target baby steps will
get you there we heard over and over
slow and steady
13 years they did it they stayed with
the baby steps 13 years
and now look at them the best is yet to
be for this couple
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
corinthians 5 17 therefore if anyone is
in christ the new creation has come
the old is gone the new is here
my friend john maxwell says talent is a
gift but character
is a choice
there you go
i mean you guys are stressed out or
hurting because you've been worried
about this stock market going one
direction or the other
maybe uh maybe 2020 scared you to death
maybe you need to get somebody in your
corner like a conscientious investment
pro to teach you these are called smart
vester pros around our place they're
people that we have vetted they have the
heart of a teacher they'll walk with you
as you learn to
build your confidence and so you can
ride the wave of something like a 2020
or the different things that happen in
the market and you just think long term
and think long term and think long term
go to ramseysolutions.com smart vester
and you can find a list of the pros in
your area the smart vester pros and you
can choose one and pick out who you're
going to work with to put yourself on
that track for baby steps millionaire
all right sam's with us sam is in
shreveport hi sam welcome to the ramsey
show
thank you for taking my call sure what's
up
i am
kind of questionable baby steps four
five and six
uh
and my question is about
concerning the investing of 15 of my
income
my employer does not offer any 401k of
any kind
and so i was wondering what should i
invest in after i max out the roth ira
are you married
no i'm not okay do you have any
self-employment income
no i do not okay
all right yeah your roth is all you've
got available to you then you max that
out and then if you want to do something
else you just buy some mutual funds get
with your smart vester pro like we were
just talking about and what you're
looking for there is a low turnover
mutual fund
a low turnover ratio on the mutual fund
like a four or five percent or less
turnover ratio
an easy way to find that is an s p 500
index fund most of those are low
turnover what low turnover means is they
don't sell the stocks mutual funds a
group of stocks
and they never sell or almost never sell
95 of the time the stocks in there and
so as those stocks go up in value as a
group you do not pay taxes on the gain
until you cash it out this is a capital
gain is what we're dealing with here
if the mutual fund sells the stocks
inside of there all of the gains are
activated each year and you have to pay
taxes on it so when you're buying a low
turnover mutual fund it's kind of buying
a rental property where if it goes from
200 000 to 300 000 in value you don't
pay taxes on that hundred thousand
dollar increase in value
until you sell it
and so that gives you the same effect of
that
in a low turnover mutual fund and that's
the best option you've got left to you
at this point
and then over time you'll probably end
up in a different employment situation
maybe you'll add some self-employment
income which you could then do a sep
on this simplified employee pension plan
additionally if you had some a little
bit of extra income nathan's and
amarillo hi nathan welcome to the ramsey
show
hey dave hey ken how are y'all great man
what's up
good hey so um i am 21 year old i've got
one year left in college i'm about to be
a senior
and uh i've got about 12 thousand
dollars sitting in my savings i'm
wondering uh if i should do something
else with it because i feel like it's
not uh
i mean it's just sitting in my savings
i'm not making any money off of it what
are you studying
uh i'm studying energy finance and
management good for you
excellent thank you
um well i mean nathan the
you're gonna need that money to either
finish school debt-free or make the
transition after school because the
transition being a move to maybe a
different city maybe some travel to do
some interviews so that money is best
used to invest in nathan rather than
worrying about some kind of mutual fund
investment at this point you are a
better investment than a mutual fund is
you're going to make more return on it
by using it to ensure that you graduate
debt-free ensure that you're able to
make your transitions without any um
it just gives you a little grease in the
wheel right ken yeah absolutely what do
you want to do you have a good idea
specifically i know the industry that
you're headed to but what would be that
great job right out of college
so that's the thing i've been thinking a
lot about that i'm not entirely sure i
have a insurance sales job that's uh
that has been asking me to work for them
down in college but i'm
thinking about
learning a trade
and uh hoping to become some type of
owner operator of uh a certain trade
fascinating well let me tell you would
you not use your degree yeah
that's true that's very true i'm just
one no no what's the actual answer
uh i don't know that's the thing is i i
really don't know um
what i want to do and i just know that i
do want to do something with my degree
to where i'm talking to other people and
helping other people i don't want to sit
behind a desk and
not talk to anyone well but when you say
energy finance
i've never heard of that degree does
that mean that you're specializing in
financing in the energy industry
sure so uh oil and gas uh you know
renewable energy stuff like that are you
interested
are you interested in finance
sure yeah absolutely um i mean i mainly
picked it up because i uh had enough
time to pick up another major
and uh but i i think that i i like
finance don't get me wrong but i would
like to do something more in the
management
aspect yeah so play that out what trade
i'm not holding you to this but what
trade are you thinking about and then
eventually working your way through the
trade maybe owning your own business
what are we talking about
so honestly it could be anything uh i've
had hvac stand up to me just because
i've had a million problems with uh hvac
and the companies that i'm using and
talking to are terrible at their job and
i'm sitting here thinking that i could
run that
uh something like an hvac business
tremendously better than the people i'm
talking to
well it sounds like you still got a lot
of searching to do but if you really
love the trades yourself meaning you
enjoy uh solving problems with your head
and your hands and then you work your
way up and eventually own your own
business you know and that finance
background that's not going to hurt you
but either way dave's advice is
absolutely right let's say you pursue
the trades coming out of college you're
going to need some of that money
to potentially do some trade
certification you need to quit picking
your career based on convenience yeah
and what's just in front of you you need
to start thinking about what's in your
heart because you you picked up this
major just because it dropped in front
of you and you didn't really give it a
lot of thought yeah and now you're
picking up hvac because you once knew
had an hvac guy didn't show up on time
um that's that's not the way you need to
analyze this i mean if you want to find
businesses that suck and get into one of
those industries
the entire world's open to you because
there's always in any industry there's
businesses that suck but let me ask you
a question you are intrigued by the
trades yes or no or is this a fancy no
i'm sorry i mean
go ahead no i'm out
are you intrigued by the traits or do
you really like the idea of working in
the trades it's something that personal
interaction with people solving a
problem is that what's drawing you or is
it just a fancy
so ken it's not necessarily the trade
itself it's uh owning my own business
and doing something better than my
competitors and helping people out along
the way
okay all right so you have an
entrepreneurial drive
so you better do your homework on this
because here's what happens
dave's exactly right you just well i've
had a bad experience with some hvac
companies and i'm going to start an uh
an hi company you're going to wake up
six months into that and you're gonna be
miserable because it's not what you
thought it was you better figure out
what problem you're trying to solve so
there's a three-part question for you
for an entrepreneur to start something
what problem do i want to solve
all right not one and it's not one that
makes money it's not an industry that
needs your help yeah it's like i have a
burning desire to solve this problem on
behalf of people so who are the people
and the problem that i'm helping i'm
solving a problem i'm helping people and
then what's the solution you get most
excited about in solving that problem if
you can figure that out now you've got
something that it's not just a business
that allows you to work for yourself and
not work for the man and if you don't do
that you're going to be a typical
entrepreneur who's jumping from idea to
idea every 20 seconds because you have
zero juice for the actual businesses and
so you you run to one thing abandon it
run to another abandon it and it's just
add in the marketplace thing i know
because i'm an entrepreneur too and so
we all haven't we all have 27 ideas in a
minute
it's just part of our the way we're
wired so be careful with that it's very
important to figure out what's burning
inside of you and then go do that not go
look for something of convenience
bad plan good hour ken thank you sir
good hour james childs and kelly daniel
in the booth i am dave ramsey your host
will be back with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you